I'm super excited to be here we're
actually just you pry saw some of the
talks bus from Peter who talked about
deep learning and how to use us a little
earlier this week as well as Jay who
talked about our s frame and sra and s
graph architecture we just came off of
sort of a busy week we had our user
conference or annual user conference
down in San Francisco which this year we
had just over a thousand data scientists
and data people super exciting so that's
good because it means that I come with a
lot of new fresh demos to share with you
guys so today I'm going to talk to you
about us and and what we're doing at bat
oh so I'm the director of product at
that oh and what's inspiring me is how
do we build new experiences new products
that create new business is ultimately
what are the things that inspire users
other business people and ultimately the
folks in my company it's all about
intelligent applications so if we look
at all of the disruptive companies that
are making waves these days all of them
are doing so by using machine learning
at the core of what they're doing but
that's pretty different than what we've
done in the past with data which was
either dat centralize it provide access
to it maybe make reporting faster but
really now it's all about the apps the
things that we can build using machine
learning models so let's jump right in
and talk about one example application
and then we'll sort of dive in and talk
about our perspective on things so this
is unexperienced I think we're all
familiar with anytime you go looking for
something to buy it all starts with a
search starts with a keyword and so
let's say that I'm looking to buy my
wife a dress maybe I'll search for dress
and I get results so this is basically
every every consumer experience online
today but the problem is as a user I
usually don't know what I'm really
looking for right I know high level
descriptors but once
gets down to trying to find just the
right thing I'm lost I don't know how to
describe these things I might know that
maybe my wife is looking for a cocktail
dress okay and I see lots of different
cocktail dresses here but they're still
all very different I can go a level
deeper and say okay well let's filter
this maybe I want a black cocktail dress
I get some that are black some that are
not let's take this guy away but the
problem is there's still many many
different options here so what are
things that we can do to change this
sort of standard slow search experience
well one is I can teach the user so if i
hover over any product here i see
different words are highlighted and
those words in this case our words that
are unique to this product so soot ash
trim I have no idea what a suit astrium
is but if I click this I get other
things that are have have that kind of
trim here okay so that still helps me
learn but it's still not sort of the
fast search experience that I'm
expecting as a user I want to get
presented objects and then very very
quickly go down to what just matters to
me so let's let's see how we can do
things differently so let's say that I'm
looking for a dress maybe I'm looking
for something that's floral but nothing
my wife likes particular thing so let's
say I want this one ok so what just
happened here is we did a very different
kind of search this is a search based on
image similarity so this completely
changes how I how I find things now so
today we're going to kind of pull away
the covers and show how we're making it
easy a dado to build applications like
this in this case search is kind of worn
out we can do a lot of things with text
and we've kind of done them all but how
do i do more advanced things how do i do
things that are more personalized and
more specific to the user
so before we get there when I think
about the process so here the person
that data scientists that built this app
and we can talk more about it is a guy
named trey kazi who's who was a speaker
here earlier this weekend and when he
and all of us start our process it's
about going from some inspirational
ideas some initial idea that ultimately
I want to take and turn it into a
product that I think is going to change
things the world my customers experience
or maybe just how I do things so the
goal is to start from inspiration and
they get to production any anything like
image similarity recommenders things
that require sort of more sophisticated
machine learning I have to figure out
how to implement those need to figure
out how to scale that ultimately i'm
usually turning these things into live
services and that's what production is
for me typically we start off with
prototyping tools so things like our
scikit-learn other things that are in
the in the Python ecosystem that you
guys are probably super stoked on and
ultimately when I go to production I
need to figure out how to translate
those systems those initial prototypes
into deployed production system and
usually that's a different ecosystem a
different set of tools so in this
process typically we all see the same
problems sophisticated machine learning
is impractical a lot of the advanced
stuff is trapped in papers and it's also
for for someone like me if I rewind I
was a physicist turn data scientists and
so when I got into machine learning I
kind of knew general concepts and I
always knew what I wanted to build but I
didn't know exactly whether or not I
needed to use SGD as an optimization
method for my recommender or a degrad
for my optimization method right and
most of us when we when we start off we
just want an algorithm that's good for a
particular task we want to build a
recommender we want to build a fraud
detector we want to build a search
experience
so it's hard to match algorithms to apps
it requires a ton of time and learning
scalings costly particularly for these
more advanced algorithms and then
finally deployment is typically week and
that's because every time I deploy a new
machine learning service i'm running a
bunch of custom code custom api is
standing up new web services and i have
no standard way to manage those models
once they're in production so first
model into production is hard but then
once I have a hundred five hundred a
thousand models running in production
how do I keep track of all of those how
do I keep track of versioning how do I
know which of those I need to prioritize
and fix to make better all of this slows
all of our creativity down there's so
many more things that we could be
building if we got rid of the boring
stuff so who's dad oh we're company
that's been around for a little over two
years originally built on the open
source project that's about seven years
old funded by any a madrone opus capital
and Vulcan and we're now a little over
45 data folks building all sorts of
stuff we're in Seattle we're just over
in fremont next to the troll and we have
one mission and that missions to
accelerate the creation of intelligent
applications so if you have an idea for
a new way of doing search
recommendations or other customer
experiences we want to make that really
really easy for you whether you're an
experienced data scientist or a
developer that's new to the data world
we want to make it easy so in the last
our products have been out for about a
year and a half and we're doing well so
these these are the folks that are using
us now for you can see this is sort of a
broad array of folks so we cover
everything from recommenders to
multi-channel advertising to content
recommendation and so on just mentioned
the data science summit which was a huge
success a little over a thousand data
scientists
awesome speakers and there's a lot of
hands-on work with us if you missed that
there will be videos and tutorials and
stuff posted online soon so stay tuned
okay that's sort of enough of that
high-level let's go down super low level
and see what it's like as a developer to
build and deploy something and so we're
going to build a restaurant recommender
here okay let's fix some of these can
everyone see this that's big enough okay
sounds good sounds good i gotta some set
okay so so GraphLab create is one of our
products we have three products and this
is access through a python api don't let
that fool you though we love python
because of the usability that's why we
chose python as sort of the our central
api the underlying architecture is all
in c++ and so we're super scalable we're
not instantiating python objects
generally ok so i'm going to go through
sort of my standard process so that
would regardless of what kind of data
product on building in this case we're
going to load some data we're going to
explore it a little build a model and
then deploy it as a service and we'll do
that in about five minutes so these are
restaurant reviews so the first thing
I'm going to do is load these reviews
see rest I need to remind myself what
this is called let's see restaurant
reviews aptly named okay so I'm going to
load this into our s frame which I don't
how many of you guys heard JS talk on s
frames here 0 people sounds good so s
frame is is basically our data frame we
built it inspired in large part to the
pandas dataframe and our data frame but
what's different about it is it's
scalable that's why there's a big ass in
front
so so it's an out of core kilometer data
structure so a decor means that I can
scale to larger than memory means if I
have a hundred gig data set even a
terabyte data set I can even I can do
that as long as I have enough disk space
to fit the data it's kilometer which
means I'm fast for analytics operations
and machine learning task this is a data
structure built specifically for machine
learning so that's good because it means
you can scale real big but the API is
very similar to two pandas and so it
should feel comfortable for you okay so
let's take a look at the data see what
we see so this is sort of the typical
Yelp data set so we have names of places
categories price range user ID rating
there's a whole review here and when it
when it happened now as a data scientist
the standard thing I'd want to do is
write a bunch of group by aggregating
histograms so I can understand the shape
of my data we got bored of doing that
over and over again and so we created
GraphLab canvas which is a simple
visualization tool that's part of
GraphLab create so here all of that
standard aggregate stuff that I'm always
doing just happens automatically the
other thing that's really cool about
this is even if my date is really big I
could have a billion rows and I'm going
to get results that are really fast and
that's because we do one pass sketches
for all of the statistics are
approximate so I see things these are
all for we built this for the San
Francisco conference so these are a
bunch of places in san francisco i don't
know if any of you have lived down there
if so you probably would recognize some
of these so pizzeria delfina turns out
to be the most reviewed restaurant in
this data set and I can learn some other
things for example the ratings if I
click here I see that the most common
rating is four stars followed by five
stars and not a whole lot less than that
so we kind of learned immediately that
these are highly skewed to to be a
positive bias and that star ratings
don't kind of tell us that much
okay so that's GraphLab canvas what we
want to do is build be able to recommend
er why because I live in Seattle and I'm
going down to San Francisco I know one
or two places but I don't know much
outside of that so let's see how that
works so I'm going to take a model and
in GraphLab we have these things called
tool kits which are basically
application or oriented bundles of
algorithms and utilities to make certain
tasks easy so I'm going to use the
recommender toolkit here and I'm going
to pass in the reviews data set and the
only thing I have to specify here is
something to make this readable by us
would idea create yes we are creating
intelligence data okay so and i'll talk
more about this but we're trying to
streamline everything everything in this
process so here i just want something
that's going to work right from the
get-go which means i don't want to have
to worry whether or not i need a
factorization machines with the ranking
loss function matrix factorization with
the ranking loss function item
similarity or if i should predict on
rating i just want to throw the data and
get something that's going to work to
start and then i can iterate later and
so what we do is based on the shape of
the data we automatically select an
algorithm that's going to do a good job
just get started we chose item
similarity for this data this data set
and that's usually a good baseline for
for recommenders we see that we had
350,000 observations so 350,000 ratings
here and thence this finished training
in less than a second on my laptop so
we're fast so now that I've now that
I've trained the model I can do
different tasks with this so I could do
some quantitative stuff so show me
precision recall okay
or I could do some predictive tasks so
predict given a user item pair give me a
score back recommend given a user
recommend top k back or get similar
items which is what we're going to do so
let's say let's say that i was in san
francisco and in need of some coffee and
i've heard that this four barrel coffee
is good stuff there any coffee
aficionados in the audience one have you
ever been to four barrel never been to
san francisco and he's any coffee
aficionados it have been to san
francisco that swears by fair about okay
good okay so i'll give you some homework
to do then so i've also heard the four
barrels very good what else do I i reran
that that's okay and this has to be a
list okay so given four barrel I'm
recommended sight glass coffee ritual
coffee roasters blue bottle coffee
bluebottles recently been making their
way up here if you've seen in pcc
they're starting to sell their new
orleans ice iced coffee coffee bar fills
coffee which is a special place and so
on don't make sense and if you do a
little digging you'll see that all of
these are artisanal super fancy six
dollar latte places so so that's great
now i know where else to go waste my
money oh let's let's look at one other
example and then we'll deploy this as a
service let's say that you know it's the
end of the week end week is just just a
day away let's say that i actually want
to look for a dive bar let's see where
are we here let's just create a lot more
so i used to live in san francisco
there's a favorite place of mine they're
called amnesia they have gypsy jazz for
free every wednesday nights you should
go
so given amnesia I'm recommended
casanova lounge Delva elbow room
make-out room El Rio these are all dive
bars in the mission in san francisco so
very different kinds of things i'm
looking for and i can still get good
recommendations for both and we just
train the recommender here while we were
sitting and chatting about it let's turn
it into is into a service and we're
going to turn it into a fault-tolerant
and scalable service so how do we do
that we have a product called predictive
services and I'm basically used that to
stand up a cluster that's running you
usually just pay that price of two lines
of code to stand that cluster up once
and then as a team usually you use this
cluster to serve all of your services
you can expand the cluster but what
we're going to do right now is just
connect to it and then add this model
that we just created so this is in ploy
and for this one I need a cheat sheet
okay get rid of that okay so this is a
state path for the predictive service
and that's going to tell me basically
what i need to get a handle for this
predictive service so now i have this
object called my deployment let's take a
look at what's running there so i see
here the state paths is an s3 bucket so
this is on AWS i see that there's three
machines that are running and they're
all in service or all part of this
cluster see the the DNS of the load
balancer so I also know now that there's
a load balancer sitting in front of
those three machines which is good that
lets me scale easily and then I see all
of the things that I've deployed as a
service and I also see that they're
versioned so this is great this means
that I can keep track of the Providence
of a model or a service and I've
connected so let's let's actually deploy
something okay so so to deploy I can do
a number of things in this case I'm
going to do the most flexible thing
which is just to create a Python
function so i can create any Python
function and then deploy that function
as a service so i'm going to create a
function called get rest restaurants
which accepts a name as input and this
is just going to call what we did before
get similar items which accepts a list
which is named and it's going to return
that return okay so very simple Python
function and then deployment just looks
like this oh I'm in ad going to give a
name for the service and so let's call
this get rests
and I pass in the function get
restaurants what did i do here no
there's already a service running so I
could add in this case i'll update
sensors are already one there so update
says this is updated diversion to use
apply changes to deploy all pending
changes so that's good so let's do that
apply changes okay alright so what's
happening now and is basically done is
basically that model that i created here
on my laptop with you guys i loaded that
to an s3 bucket after it's loaded there
each of the nodes and this cluster are
notified that there's a new model you
should go pick them up it's written to
each of the nodes and then in this case
since we're updating instead of a new
model we roll over from the old model to
the new model and the service just stays
up and so in principle it's up now and I
can query it as a restful service so I
could query this with curl of course but
we also have Python Java JavaScript
clients for this so I'm going to query I
give the name of the service which was
get rests get rests and then I have to
specify a name equals whatever i'm
looking for let's say four barrel coffee
since we saw those results before four
barrel coffee alright let's see if this
works so we see that we're connecting to
the load balancer and then I'm given a
JSON response back which is that rank
list of items if I quarry this one more
time oops I did something stupid this
comes back almost instantaneously and
that's because we have a caching layer
and so for high-throughput repeated
queries we're going to be smart about
how we serve those so that means that
you know the worst case for simple
things like recommend we're doing 100
millisecond response time and then for
high-throughput
repeated queries then we're down in the
single digits for a lot of queries so
that's great we're done I can directly
integrate this with a nap I didn't have
to go talk to ops I didn't have to do
something that would typically slow me
down and I definitely didn't have to
stand up that whole web service that
would have taken even if I'm good it
probably would have taken a week or two
weeks to put up operationalize and
you're not going to have all of the
model management that we have here so
that's that's sort of one example of the
end and vision to make things fast
simple and easy any questions actually
we're small enough groups that I don't
mind stopping for a question or two
before moving on now okay we'll charge
to then I'm so sophisticated machine
learning made easy tool kits so we saw
this here there's a few principles that
are guiding us we want to make it really
easy to get started fast like the
recommender toolkit and then we want to
make it really easy to rapidly iterate
and so so that basically means having
fast and efficient data structures and
all of the mechanics so that you can try
out many many models and improve upon
that baseline that you start with and
then fine finally we want to make it
easy to combine to create new apps that
you've never thought of so this is what
we just did basically zoom down so for a
recommender toolkit just a handful of
lines of code to create that recommend
recommender and get recommendations and
then from here we'll dive into Image
Search which was used for the search
demo at the beginning and then our plant
plan as a company is to grow these more
and more so we have around nine toolkits
right now and and we're looking to
expand those pretty significantly in the
coming year our focus is in making these
higher level tasks like recommenders
like sentiment analysis easier for any
developer
okay something very different another
way that we can make machine learning
very easy is to make feature engineering
easier and one way of doing that is to
use something called transfer learning
which is one of the things that Peter
covered in his tutorial so here I'll
give you the five-minute crash course so
the general just with transfer learning
is that I'm going to train a model on
one task and then use it for another
task and and the way I'm going to use it
is basically to extract features i'm
going to use it as part of my future
building pipeline for images when we
think about an image being processed
through a neural net one way one image i
always have in my mind is is this
representation of the image how it
changes as i go through each of the
layers and a neural net and there's a
couple different things that happen but
a couple of the fundamental ones is if
it's a neural net that's been well
trained then as i head down this this
representation tation path as i get
deeper i have features that are more
relevant to the prediction task at hand
and then the second thing is we've also
compressed the beta so we've gotten rid
of all the in principle we've gotten rid
of a lot of the noise and we've kept
only the components that matter for our
task and that turns out to be super
useful when we do transfer learning so
this is the simple concept to transfer
learning I start off with something like
labeled data and I train a model to
predict that predict those labels and
then I use that model to extract
features in new images that weren't part
of that set and then I can create a
simpler model like clustering like a
k-means model nearest neighbors model
which is what we're going to do or a
classification model and so on okay so
let's see how this works so to start off
a very very simple app is just a photo
tagging app and so in this case we've
trained a deep learning model on this
very complicated neural net that's very
popular what's the architecture actually
called is it is called Alex 9 I thought
so yeah so at this is trained on a
topology called Alex net which is out of
Jeff Hinton's group at Berkeley it has
many many layers and a lot of different
operations in between but once you in
this case we've trained it on the image
net dataset which is a little over a
million images and a thousand tags and
then we've deployed that as a service
just like we did for the recommender so
that so that now it's a very simple
service I send a picture I get labels
and the confidence of those labels back
so in this case Siamese cat this is the
label and this was in the training set
so it's clearly a Siamese cat select
another image goes up predictions come
back Thunder snake this was a thunder
snake and then let's say I looking for
something completely different
oscilloscope this is one of my favorites
so what we're doing right now this is
getty images being slow we're just
coring getty images for other images
that were not part of the training set
click on something completely different
see what we get oscilloscope let's try
one other thing anyone looking to tag
something in the audience any objects we
have no human features but there's a
thousand other things that are
interesting they could be animals they
could be cars I'll take one one
suggestion mountain I don't know that
there's actually place like geographic
features in here let's see what we get
there's actually not I'm guessing that
let's see
that looks pretty mountainy alp it has
one of the Alps in there I guess okay so
so transfer learning so the idea here is
we trained up a model on this data set
it can it does very well at predicting
images that are similar to images in
this data set but what we're going to do
is take that model and then use it to
extract features for a completely
separate task which is to to find
similar shoes so to go along with the
dress that I found my wife I can find
her shoes as well so how's that work
this case i'm not going to type but I'll
just walk you through the code so let's
take a look so we have many different
kinds of shoes here I see sneakers flats
cowboy boots all sorts of things right
just six thousand different shoes here
so it's a lot to sift through here's how
it works I'm going to load this model
that imagenet model that we had used for
photo tag and then let's extract
features for one image to understand it
and then we'll move on so in this case
this is an input I see what it is and
then I'm just going to call dot extract
features and pass in this image and see
what we get back I get something that's
highly meaningful to all of you I'm sure
so it's it's basically a big array it
obviously doesn't mean much we talked
about two things that this is doing one
that these features should have high
predictive power and to that our data
should have been compressed so let's
understand how much the data has been
compressed so I started off with an
image which was 256 x 256 by three color
channels so let's just look at that
lengths relative to this new links so i
started off with basically 200,000
dimensions and I've compressed that down
too
a little over four thousand dimensions
that's highly useful because it means
that I can just directly go and use
something like nearest neighbors and
it'll probably give me reasonable
overall results so let's see so here I'm
gonna we did that for 1 i'm not going to
make you sit through extracting features
for all of these even though we're
pretty fast we've done that already and
here i'm just going to create a nearest
neighbors model or the only features i'm
using are those extracted features from
deep learning those deep features so
we'll do this this is starting and done
so in principle if this worked if we
have high predictive power and those
features then we'll see search results
that are meaningful so let's say i'm
looking for something like this
hopefully it goes with the cocktail
dress that i was looking for so it's a
black heel obviously it's very sort of
strappy area i don't know how to
describe that but i want to find more
things like this so I'm just going to
take the nearest neighbors model query
it for this image and give me the top
top K of 10 back and then the rest of
this code is just so that we see it here
let's see what we get okay so this was
the query and then these are the 9 most
similar images in the data set seems
like it's working they're all black
they're all high heels they're all sort
of Aries strappy let's look at something
very different how about a cowboy boot
does same thing we're just going to
query for this and let's see what we get
so the next nearest is also a cowboy
boot and then it's followed by other
boots that are a similar shape or a
shade so that makes sense we'll do one
more which is I was at a customer and
they wouldn't make sure that I wasn't
canning all this and so they said well
do something else ok so this is a flat
let's see what we get for things similar
to this so we get in this case the
dominant thing is not color but the
shape so these are all clearly flats so
in this case again the core intelligence
was about taking a model where were we
up here taking a model that was well
known to do well for one task which was
classify images into into different
categories and then re-appropriating it
using it as part of my future building
pipeline to extract features and it
looks like we have good predictive power
because I can query three very very
different things and get extremely
similar things and that's only using the
images there's no text there's no tags
there's there's there's nothing else
that's doing the job of that nearest
neighbors search except for those deep
features super powerful so the at the
end of the day we're all about making it
fast for any developer data scientist to
go end and take an idea and get it
turned into a fault-tolerant predictive
service that you can directly integrate
with a nap and serve the world people
have been using us for a while now and
the bottom line is were making them all
very very productive so babycenter maybe
Center we there's a developer who was
originally a DBA and she decided to
build her she got inspired to build a
recommender originally it was a baby
nyan recommender that she wanted to
build and then she found a business use
case which is similar which was
basically a Content recommender so a ton
of their folks their site basically
serves their community and their revenue
comes from ads and so the more relevant
information you give the community the
more they stay on the site and the
higher the revenue from ads goes she was
able to in a hack week bill
deploy her first recommender and she had
no experience in machine learning before
this she had taken a Coursera class on
machine learning like many of us have
and and this was her her way in she's
now running in production and has moved
on to three other use cases including
that baby rename recommender actually
she's gone back to that as well as
basically the ability to predict the
term that that a new mother is and which
is pretty cool magazine Luiza small team
of developers they'd already built a
recommender but they came visited us and
they found out that they could basically
do the same thing and just about an hour
of work with us and then they've gone on
to improve their existing system make it
simpler but more importantly replace
their recommender with a more accurate
and relevant one that's now making them
more money so those both of those guys
are kind of more on the earlier end of
the skill spectrum for machine learning
but for super experienced folks as well
we do well for them so this is the core
research team at Pandora that's
responsible for making Pandora's
recommendations better and and they're
using us because they can iterate faster
they can try more things faster
similarly at livingsocial these guys are
targeting their users with personalized
emails so you can think about that
either as as marketing or
personalization and they're using us to
iterate faster now that finally glass
door they're basically running their job
ranking engine on us and that's through
a series of both taking all of the text
descriptors of those job job rex
creating classifiers to extract tags to
describe those jobs as well as all the
way through to feeding that into a real
time ranking engine ultimately these
these are all just a handful of examples
of folks that are extremely productive
they took projects that otherwise would
have been three months to six months
and turn them into ones that are weeks
instead so what I talked through here is
our platform which has three different
products so graph them create Jay talked
about s frames and s graph these are our
fundamental data structures to make all
data manipulation and exploration tasks
with machine learning easier out of core
computation tools specifically for
feature engineering rich data type
supports which means things like you can
keep your data as a nested dictionary in
an array and directly feed that into an
algorithm you don't have to do this
annoying process of going back and forth
between bents data and sparse data
machine learning we have a lot I kind of
touched on a few key pieces looking at
recommenders neural nets and feature
extraction for for image similarity we
looked at nearest neighbors we're now
upwards of 50 algorithms that are all
the most scalable and best
implementations that we've known of and
then we use predictive services to take
those models and deploy them as as
services in the example I gave we were
doing a very simple service which was
just a recommendation service so give me
similar items given this one but if you
remember I wrote an arbitrary Python
function you can there's it is arbitrary
so if you have extra rules that you want
to add in if you want to make make calls
from 10 different models and then
combine them in that function you can do
that so there's a ton of flexibility and
how we've designed designed that service
architecture and then what I didn't
cover today is data distributed so we do
a distributed machine learning and
various distributed tasks so if you have
a complicated pipeline and there's a
couple portions that are taking too long
need them to complete in less than a day
or less than an hour we can paralyze
those
we have a handful of algorithms that do
that but also just a very nice similarly
intuitive API to the predictive service
API where i can write a function and
then deploy that function across a
cluster machines so if you want to learn
more or just try it out it's always best
to just get your hands on the on the
software and try out yourself go to data
comm and and the download and get coding
free trial works for 30 days and then
you probably talk to me somewhere in
there to see what you're doing what you
want to build my emails here Scully at
bedok calm but I hope that you'll go out
and help create an intelligent world and
where if you want to do that by yourself
I'm happy to give you lots of resources
if you want to do that with us we're
hiring for all sorts of things so we're
45 folks right now and and scrambling to
get other awesome people that want to
build stuff like this so with that I'll
call it and take any questions so you
guys have